[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOE BINNEY: I'm
Joe Binney, and I'm
VP of product
engineering at Robinhood.
Robinhood is the free
stock trading app.
Every other stock trading
service charges $5 to $10.
We do it for $0.
Robinhood today has
over a million users.
And we've been able to grow
with a very small team.
Android users love Robinhood.
We've more than
doubled our user base.
And with 4.6 stars, Robinhood
is the highest-rated stock
brokerage on the Play store.
DAN HILL: I'm Dan Hill.
I'm an Android
developer at Robinhood.
We're an Android team of two.
We kind of pride ourselves
on staying agile and being
very fast.
In Android Studios, there's
speed and stability.
It really lets us stay
in the zone for longer
and not have to kind of worry
about the administration.
I mean, the mark of a good
tool is that it's not visible,
it's not in your way.
It's just there.
And it's something
that you can use.
One of my favorite things
about Android Studios,
all the shortcuts
that it offers.
There is one that's
really great.
It's a shortcut to
look up shortcuts.
And basically it will
display it in line
with what the
keyboard shortcut is.
Or you can kind
of use it to learn
all the different shortcuts.
The new emulator is fast.
You can hardware accelerate
and you use your machine's GPU
to make it faster.
One of my favorite
things to show off
is the trade animation.
It's really satisfying
to kind of swipe
up, kind of see your trade
metaphorically go out.
Very tactical way to
interact with the stock.
JOE BINNEY: Having
really powerful tools
enables our very small team
to have a large impact.
DAN HILL: In
Android Development,
we're always
jumping around files
and learning different config
files and Java classes.
And Android Studio has
always held responsive enough
to go at the speed
that you want to go.